within the Star Wars universe we will
tend to have a group that we identify
with a group that we'd like to think
would be part of if given the chance be
it the Jedi Sith rebels or in this case
the bounty hunters well first introduced
to the bounty hunters in the original
trilogy and they don't seem to do them
much justice as Boba Fett and the other
bounty hunters have a very limited
screen time when we finally get to see
Boba Fett in action in Return of the
Jedi
during the fight scene outside of
Jabba's palace a half-blind Han Solo's
stumbling around manages to cause he
step back to malfunction leading him to
almost comically fall into the Sarlacc
pit despite only having a total of 27
words spoken and just over six minutes
of screen time Boba Fett became a fan
favorite which strikes me as rather odd
because besides looking like a cool
character the movies present him as
nothing more than a hired gun the
characters popularity continued to grow
and over the years there have been
several talks about a standalone Boba
Fett movie we can assume that this may
have had some influence on Lucas when
given Jango Fett a much larger role in
the Clone Wars ultimately one can argue
that Boba Fett is one of the main
reasons that bounty hunters are explored
in the extended universe they quickly
earn the reputation as some of the
galaxy's most dangerous individuals and
they were known for their ability to
hunt down and assassinate Jedi and Sith
we do see this to a certain extent in
the prequels when Jango Fett goes
toe-to-toe of obi-wan and doesn't look
too far out of place when we see the
Jedi and Sith in combat they often brush
off any non force-sensitive foe with
ease but with the bounty hunters that
isn't quite the case one of the main
reasons that the bounty hunters were
able to call such a problem for the Jedi
and the Sith was the vast array of tools
and weapons available to them the
weapons are the most commonly associated
with bounty hunters are their blaster
pistols despite them being small and
compact they possessed impressive
stopping power and with multiple
attachments that allowed for noise
reduction there were popular choice
amongst assassins the arsenal of the
bounty hunters also included stun dots
to immobilize targets as well as toxic
darts for discreet kills there are
weapons they use that completely
disregarded the element of surprise
including wrists rockets grenades
cluster missiles and flamethrowers these
weapons were all capable of doing
massive damage and they were quite often
used by bounty hunters when they wanted
to quickly escape or finish a job it was
pretty difficult for anyone who had a
bounty on their head to ever assume that
they were really safe as the bounty
hunters jetpack and built-in cutting
torch made it possible for them to reach
areas that may not be accessible to most
many of the weapons and gadgets that
we've just mentioned our reasons why the
bounty hunters were such formidable foes
for the Sith and the Jedi but they
always had one or two additional tricks
at their disposal the whipcord was used
to entangle bounties that would need to
be captured but returned alive we see
Jango used the whip called quite
effectively during his confrontation
with obi-wan making it much harder for
the Jedi to use his lightsaber given
their line of work it's inevitable that
bounty hunters would be involved in
close combat which is why many of them
carried vibra blades allowing them to
cut down enemies at close proximity or
being able to fend off the attacks of a
lightsaber
it's impossible to discuss the weapons
in the equipment of the bounty hunters
without mentioning their iconic armor a
lot of people have speculated what the
armor is made of over the years and
there are some theories that make very
valid arguments almost similar to that
of Django and Boba Fett's is most likely
made of Juris still the same metal that
was used to construct the armor of Darth
Vader Jura still was quite robust and
fares well versus blaster fire however
it's unlikely that the ama offers much
protection against any heavy form of
weaponry and even lightsabers jewish
still being quite clunky which suggests
that some kind of padding or leather
hide may be worn underneath to help with
any chafing and increase mobility the
problem of mobility and flexibility is
still of course an issue of this kind of
armor which is why we see many bounty
hunters ditched a heavy suit in favor
for light armor or even just regular
clothing there are definitely pros to
this light armor approach not standing
out being one of them the sight of a
fully suited up mercenary is likely to
spook most potential targets making the
light armor approach and plain clothing
options much more viable for discreet
jobs being able to pass themselves off
as a civilian or common smuggler along
with the added mobility is clearly
something that some bounty hunters value
over the added protection of a full suit
of armor one of the things that I enjoy
most about the bounty hunters is that
they're essentially this motley group of
mercenaries made up of individuals all
throughout the universe there are
certain races that have become pretty
well associated with the bounty hunters
such as the Mandalorians who already
considered some of the fiercest warriors
in the galaxy that couple of their
skills in combat the constant search for
glory and their neutrality in most
conflicts that did not involve them made
them almost perfect bounty hunters
anyone could essentially become a bounty
hunter ranging from human to any alien
race you can think of there are even
tales of an assassin droid who went by
the name of ig-88 who quickly became one
of the most infamous bounty hunters in
the galaxy some of you may recognize the
Droid as ig-88 made an appearance in the
Empire Strikes Back before appearing in
the host of comics as one of the faders
preferred mercenaries
now this video wouldn't really be
complete without us taking a look at
some of the most influential and
notorious bounty hunters in the Star
Wars universe I think one of the coolest
characters to come from the Clone Wars
TV show and the Marvel Star Wars comic
series is CAD Bane his appearance looks
straight out of a spaghetti western as
Bane was known for wearing a white
burned hat and more than a pair of
blaster pistols which really gave him
that gunslinger vibe after a
confrontation over sith a prolonged four
stroke left CAD Bane requiring breathing
troops to survive
unlike most bounty hunters CAD Bane did
not use a jet pack but he preferred the
use of rocket boots when it came to
keepin up of the Sith and the Jedi he
was considered the most feared and
notorious bounty hunter in the galaxy
and many have theorized that he had a
hand in training a young Boba Fett the
adventures of CAD Bane innumerous and
they deserved their own video but there
are a few worth mentioning during the
Clone Wars
CAD Bane was captured by the Republic
and taken to a detention center in
Khorasan
we then find out that CAD Bane had been
hired by moralo eval a crime boss
working for Count Dooku Bane had allowed
himself to be captured to gain access to
the prison that eval was located in he
paid several inmates to stage a prison
riot and in the commotion with the help
from a disguised obi-wan Bane eval and
Kenobi were able to escape the prison
Bane also took part in one of the most
dangerous tournaments in history the
winners of the tournament on Sereno were
given the Joe of kidnapping Chancellor
Palpatine the tournament itself featured
the best bounty hunters in the galaxy
and the last five standing after a
series of tasks would be victorious to
no surprise
CAD Bane was amongst the survivors and
as a result he would later lead the
mission to capture Palpatine over the
years Bane had numerous altercations of
obi-wan and Anakin and after finding out
that obi-wan had tricked him while in
disguise he swore vengeance upon the
Jedi
in asajj ventress we have one of the
most unique bounty hunters it's uncommon
to see a force-sensitive bounty hunter
but after being betrayed by her masa
Dooku who attempted to have her killed
she had lost all sense of direction and
was forced into exile she eventually
joined Boba Fett and his crew for a
simple escort mission upon discovering
that the cargo was a young woman being
used as ransom Ventress began to
sympathize but she still had every
intention in making the delivery that is
until Boba Fett revealed how small her
cut of the job was compared to the rest
she then turned on the bounty hunter for
stroking him and leaving him tied and
gagged in the box that once held their
hostage she delivered the cargo and
collected the credits with the client
not knowing that the cargo box contained
Boba Fett and not the young girl she
then returned the girl safely collected
an additional sum of credits as a reward
Ventress then returned to both his crew
splitting the credits evenly between
them even leaving FETs money with Bossk
another bounty hunter you may recognize
from the original trilogy Ventress gives
us quite an interesting character a
slave who became a Jedi and eventually a
Sith she's an extremely capable bounty
hunter and one of the best trackers of
all time but unlike most bounty hunters
she has a conscience which conflicts
with her job despite this making her job
a little bit more difficult she
continued working as a bounty hunter
where she would eventually meet Quinlan
vos and maverick or great Jedi turned
bounty hunter himself the book dark
disciple chronicles the adventures of
the two for those of you who were
interested there are some honorable
mentions of course black Crescent on the
famous Wookiee bounty hunter was known
for his work with the Hutt cartel the
scar on his left eye was given to him by
an older ob1 when he attempted to kill
the Jedi for those of you thinking about
Django and Boba we will know who Django
and Boba Fett are and I feel like in
order for me to do them justice I would
have to devote an entire video to them I
feel like overall the bounty hunters
have this undeserved reputation as being
pure evil yes at times their moral
compass can be a bit shaky but they
essentially work for the highest bidder
if you have enough credits then there's
a good chance you have the bounty
hunters on your side
another reason we don't often see them
on the side of the Republic might have
something to do with the Republic and
the Jedi specifically disagreeing with
the Bounty Hunter's approach of whatever
it takes to get the job done you can
definitely make the argument that most
of their actions beat assassinations or
kidnappings make them inherently evil
I'd argue that quite often their actions
are driven by monetary gain and not
enjoyment most bounty hunters are
probably desensitized and see everything
as a job that being said there are
almost definitely some unsavory and evil
individuals who see bounty hunting as
the perfect job I guess the reason I
like the bounty hunters is because they
add another dynamic to the conflict
between the Empire and the Republic they
act almost like a tool or a weapon
available for both sides to use if they
desire I hope you guys enjoyed today's
video it's been a while since we've made
any Star Wars content and this was the
first video voted on by the patrons so I
hope you guys enjoyed it if you did then
let me know what you thought in the
comments below
but as always I've been your host
mythology and fiction explained